[Music]
on march 5th
how did this world get so broken i
believe that we can be unified
again but someone has to take the first
step
all right let's roll
from the studio that brought you frozen
hold on
oh we were doing a jumpy thing oh so
sorry my bad
raya and the last dragon rated pg in
theaters or order it on disney plus with
premiere access march 5th
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't
trust anyone
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is raya
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore peace
we must find the last dragon i wish to
join this
fellowship of hickory
let's go we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching please let this
be it
who said that we really need your help
ah i'm gonna be real with you
i'm not like the best dragon have you
ever done like a group project but
there's like that one kid who didn't
pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grave uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the good broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just changed dragons can do that look
how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premiere access
march 5th
bye